imaginons une fusée qui se déplace dans
le vide de l'espace et qui possède une
certaine masse m qui avance à la vitesse
v selon une direction horizontal et qui
possède une cuillère par laquelle
s'échappera du carburant ou en tout cas
de la matière qui va permettre à la
fusée de se propulser
donc on imagine car certains instants
suivants d'été la fusée a perdu de la
masse sa nouvelle masse cm plus dé m
avec une variation dm qui est négative
elle a éjecté une petite bulle de
matières donc dans la masse et moins dé
m une masse positive ici donc dm et bien
négatif
à la vitesse v e la vitesse d'éjection
de cette matière par rapport à la fusée
et que de cette façon la vitesse de la
fusée a changé la fusée s'est propulsé
vers l'avant et donc ça va nouvelle
vitesse et v + dvd une certaine
variation
notre objectif ici ça va être de
déterminer la variation de vitesse de la
fusée dv donc savoir comment la fusée se
propulse en fonction de la vitesse
d'éjection du gaz et de la masse qui a
été éjecté pour faire ça on va utiliser
le principe d'action réaction c'est à
dire la conservation de la quantité de
mouvement et en particulier on va
imaginer que la fusée se situe dans le
vide de l'espace qu'elle ne subit en
particulier aucune force de gravité
aucune force extérieure qui pourrait
modifier sa quantité de mouvement et
donc la quantité de mouvements du
système ici qui ne contient que la fusée
doit être la même que la quantité de
mouvement ici après qui contient cette
fois ci la fusée et la bulle de matières
qui a été éjecté une petite subtilité
ici c'est que la vitesse d'éjection est
mesurée dans le référentiel de la fusée
c'est par rapport à la fusée que la
bulle de matière est éjecté à cette
vitesse v e et donc dans ce référentiel
que l'on regarde dans lequel la fusée a
initialement une vitesse grand v et bien
la bulle de matières a en réalité une
vitesse v e - grand v si on se repère
dans ce référentiel là
alors commençons on peut
écrire la quantité de mouvement de la
fusée à l'instant initial la quantité de
mouvement paix c'est la masse fois la
vitesse mais à l'instant suivant la
quantité de mouvement est scindée en
deux il faut additionner la quantité de
mouvements de cette bulle de matières
qui vient d'être éjecté et la quantité
de mouvement de la fusée qui a changé de
masse et de vitesse bon et bien la
quantité de mouvements de cette bulle
c'est sa masse donc moins dm
fois sa vitesse v e - v
alors comme je disais ici faut faire
bien attention - dm est une grandeur
positive puisque dmc la variation de
masse de la fusée qui est négative la
fusée a perdu de la masse et s'il faut
donc rajouter un signe négatif puisque
la quantité de mouvements de cette bulle
de matière est dirigé vers la gauche
vers l'arrière de la fusée dans le sens
opposé de sa vitesse
à cette quantité de mouvement on doit
ajouter celle de la fusée qui est sa
masse sa nouvelle masse m + dm fois sa
nouvelle vitesse v +
dvs que nous dit newton ce que nous dit
la conservation de la quantité de
mouvement c'est que ces deux quantité de
mouvement ici doivent être égales la
quantité avant doit être conservée pour
obtenir la quantité d'après
alors on peut développer cette égalité
mv
est égal à 7 cette première grandeur ici
qu'on peut développer donc on les deux -
ici ça nul on obtient des m facteur
devaient eux - vais donc dmv e - dmv
plus tout ceci donc plus élevé plus mdv
plus dmv
et plus des mtv
lors ici on voit que les mv se
simplifier
les des mv s'annulent
est ici cette grandeur dm fois dvc une
grandeur qui est très petit puisque
toutes les variations ici d'été des vdm
sont des variations qu'on considère
infinitésimale on imagine un intervalle
de temps très faible et donc dé m x dv
on a le produit de deux grandeurs
infinitésimale on peut le négliger on
fait ici du calcul différentiel
est donc cette équation qui traduit la
conservation de la quantité de mouvement
se simplifie grandement et on obtient
simplement que 0 est égal à dmv eu
plus mdv
alors on va pouvoir réarrangé cette
équation pour obtenir la variation de
vitesse c'est ça qui nous intéresse
donc la variation de vitesse de la fusée
alors on va passer ceux ci de l'autre
côté on obtient un signe - et on obtient
- v e dm sur m
cette équation c'est la version
différentiel la version infinitésimale
de l'équation de tchaïkovski elle nous
dit que la variation de vitesse de la
fusée est relié à la vitesse à laquelle
l egypte le carburant le gaz est le
rapport entre la masse qui a été éjecté
et la masse totale de la fusée donc plus
la fusée et éjecte le gaz rapidement
plus elle va accélérer rapidement et
plus la fusée éjecte une grande quantité
de masse plus élevé accélérer rapidement
alors maintenant on peut passer à
l'étape suivante et se demander quelle
serait la variation de vitesse si la
fusée accéléré constamment pendant un
certain intervalle de temps qui cette
fois n'est pas un film saisit mal donc
on va imaginer que la fusée accélère et
en particulier que l'éjection du gaz se
fait à une vitesse constante que cette
vitesse v e ici reste constante au cours
du temps
l'idée c'est qu'on va intégrer les deux
côtés de l'équation c'est à dire faire
la somme des variations infinitésimales
de la vitesse sur un intervalle de temps
qui n'est pas infinitésimale pour
obtenir la variation totale de la
vitesse entre un instant initial et un
instant finale donc on peut commencer
par intégrer la partie à gauche de
l'équation le terme de gauche on intègre
dv par rapport à v entre véhi une
vitesse initiale et vf la vitesse finale
de la fusée donc ça c'est assez simple
intégrer c'est simplement donc si on
remplace les v par des x pour y voir
plus clair c'est simplement l'intégrale
de 1 x dx est donc en fait l'intégrale
de la fonction un s'adonne x évalué
entre les bornes c'est à dire qu'on
obtient vf - velits la vitesse finale -
la vitesse initiale ce qu'on peut noter
directement delta v c'est la variation
de vitesse de la fusée entre l'instant
initial et l'instant finale
d'autre part on aimerait intégrer ce
terme à droite qui semble un peu plus
complexe intégré l'on va voir qu'en
réalité il est assez simple intégrer
aussi donc ici on a moins vieux qui est
une constante donc on peut le sortir de
l'intégrale
intégrale de dm sur m ici on intègre par
rapport à la variable m par rapport à la
masse entre une masse initiale et une
masse final la masse initiale de la
fusée la masse finale de la fusée alors
ici pour y voir plus clair ici on à
l'intégrale de un sur six fois dx donc
on à l'intégrale de la fonction 1 sur x
et une primitive de 1 sur x c'est le
logarithme 2x le logarithme né paie rien
de x évalué entre les bornes
donc ici on a moins v e fois le
logarithme n'était rien de msf - le
logarithme n'était rien de mdi
alors ici si vous connaissez les
propriétés du logarithme on reconnaît
que la soustraction de de logarithmes
c'est le logarithme de la division des
deux arguments donc ici on a finalement
- v e fois le logarithme de la masse
final sur la masse initiale
et pour terminer en passant le signe -
ici dans le logarithme - log d'une
certaine grandeur c'est le log de l'
inverse de cette grandeur et donc ceci
est égal à v e fois le logarithme de la
masse initiale sur la masse final
donc pourrait écrire cette équation on
n'obtient que la variation vitesse total
de la fusée est égale à la vitesse
d'éjection du gaz fois le logarithme du
rapport entre la masse initiale de la
fusée et la masse finale c'est cette
équation c'est une équation qui est
crucial fondamentale en aéronautique en
aérospatiale c'est l'équation de
tchaïkovski la variation de vitesse
d'une fusée est égale à la vitesse
d'éjection du gaz fois le logarithme du
rapport entre la masse initiale de la
fusée et la masse finale après avoir
éjecté son carburant